so your office is all the way down at
the end
you have your own attached bathroom by
the way oh um here's one of our best
researchers dick Hey hello there what's
up dude
glad to see there's another brother in
this stuff in Belize so this is um gonna
be your assistant Genevieve Genevieve
what is this shining man all black
people have the shine you never shine
with another black person before no I
grew up in a white neighborhood and then
went to Tulsa I've met other black
people before but not like this you got
to get shined at by another black person
first and then you get it's kind of like
Facebook what up dude so every black
person has this is Kobe listen yo what
up Wow
Denzel Washington I'm here I'm present
and I will always be around
lil jon-jon welcome break glad to have
you on board
Oh what's up Barack Obama hmm would that
be something that Barack Obama just
showed up your startup paperwork's right
over here man you gotta be more careful
learning to use the shot tune in and out
otherwise you won't be able to sort out
who's talking
Coco
drink some 45
[Music]
so everything okay right listen for
Morgan Morgan Freeman he will guide you
listen to my voice right now just stay
calm focus on that white man
everything's going to be okay
don't you finish up this paperwork bring
it to Jennifer in my office
now pick up that letter open and kill
that white man
[Music]